so then part two of the implosion of
Donald Trump's lawyer Rudy Rudy Giuliani
is after putting out that unintelligible
statement I told you about earlier where
it sort of seemed like he was
backtracking on some of the things he
said about the hundred and thirty
thousand dollar stormy Daniels hush
money repayment by Trump to Michael
Cohen Giuliani appeared on ABC Sunday
morning talk show this week and he
dismissed his own statements as mere
rumors and then contradicted himself
multiple times right they I'm gonna play
this for you and I want to prepare you
because of the hyper normalization right
are becoming accustomed to realities
that would have been inconceivable
before the Trump era the interview I'm
about to play might not immediately
strike you as the unhinged drivel that
it is but we have to contextualize it
I'm about to play a clip for you from an
interview where the attorney charged
with speaking to Robert Muller on the
behalf of the President of the United
States is being interviewed this is not
some lawyer that your landlord hires to
evict the tenant right this is the
former mayor of New York City hired by
the President of the United States to
represent him in something that could
conceivably expose alleged criminal
activity by a sitting president and this
is how his lawyer represents him on
national television
take a look but on the other day you
also told BuzzFeed though that at some
point after the 2016 election Michael
Cohen had complained to some people that
he hadn't been paid by Donald Trump and
that so then you said Cohen met with
Trump and told him and Giuliani said
that will cover your expenses they work
at this $35,000 a month retainer after
that so so the president didn't know
about this
after the campaign but can't say that I
mean I at some point yes but it could
have been recently it could have been a
while back those are the facts but we're
still working on and that you know maybe
in a little bit of dispute this is more
rumor than it is anything else well
that's what you said you said that to
BuzzFeed but Rudy Giuliani says these
are mere rumors and George
Stephanopoulos points out well you're
the source like you're I'm quoting you
here if you're dismissing the stormy
Daniels hush money repayment and
installments from Trump to Cohen as a
rumor that's a rumor you started so how
does Rudy Giuliani respond this is his
answer to that but here's the well yeah
I mean that's that's
one of the possibilities and one of the
rumors the reality is you stated it as
fact well maybe I did but I was right
now I'm at the point where I'm learning
and I can only I can't prove that I can
just say it's rumor I could prove it's
rumor but I can't prove it's fact
yeah it's rumor that's right he can
prove it's a rumor of a fact but he's
not yet ready to prove the factual
nature of the rumor of the fact which by
the way all came from him didn't Trump
hire this guy like wouldn't the first
thing he would go to trump and say is
well give me the facts so that I don't
end up spreading rumors on television
right like the is Trump admitting to
pain copain Cohen back or not and if you
can't get the information from the guy
who's just hired you maybe this is not a
guy you should be working for right and
here it continues and it only gets worse
you but you've said is it it isn't you
said as a matter of fact on Hannity and
BuzzFeed you talk to the world I don't
know how do you separate fact and
opinion that's opinion I'll say this is
my opinion and when I state a fact also
you said the president worked out a
retainer agreement with Michael Cohen
after the election order to repay him a
little settlement to stormy Daniels the
second part the second part of it the
last part of it the the retainer
agreement was to repay expenses which
turns out to have included this one to
the woman the asan Saturday Night Live
last night trying to make more money and
now our NDA with her seems to be
irrelevant because she wants to break it
up because she wants to make a lot more
money than hundred and thirty thousand I
never thought a hundred and thirty
thousand I know this sounds funny to
people there at home I never thought a
hundred thirty thousand was a real
payment it's a nuisance payment when I
settle this for when it was real or a
real possibility it's a couple million
dollars not not a hundred thirty
thousand let's get back to the couple
million dollars thing because that's
stunning language has no meaning anymore
right even though he literally went on
hannity and said this is what took place
we should have realized that what he
meant was these are rumors which i'm
creating about what took place it's not
actually what happened it's my opinion
as just a random guy about one
possibility of what might have happened
it's Orwellian doublespeak at its finest
and then at the end he throws that thing
in where he says listen 130,000 dollars
isn't even really big enough to be a
payoff for something serious anyway
this would have been if I was involved
in actually settling this it would have
been a couple million dollars that's not
a great thing to say that's exactly what
stormy Daniels was saying during the 60
Minutes interview which is she only
agreed to accept a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars because she was being
intimidated but she actually would have
wanted and potentially could have gotten
more based on the damage that she could
have done to Donald Trump before the
campaign it is a comedy of boneheaded
stupidity and then of course the final
question is well why hasn't Trump been
honest about all this but you don't go
away 430-thousand of a Meritor dude call
it a settlement payment the President
did make these payments to Michael Cohen
over the course of 2017 according to you
then why did on April 5th why did the
president deny any knowledge of the
payments when in fact well I don't know
I don't know when the president learned
about it he could have learned about it
after or not connected the whole thing
at at that time it was crazy
Trump was just so confused he had no
idea what was going on
this is gaslighting folks plain and
simple and it might be catalyzed by
incompetence in the people surrounding
Trump but the impact is gaslighting as I
have been discussing and this confuses
the average person apparently Trump was
also confused because Trump lied because
Rudy said Trump made the payment but
here's Rudy saying that the word of the
payment was just a rumor that he started
it's not actually something that he's
investigated it makes no sense and it's
makes such little sense that even Neil
Cavuto as I told you about earlier on
the program had to go out there and say
mr. president you're really not making
any sense here as soon as we heard that
North Korea was open to denuclearization
the comitted trumpets immediately said
wow Trump did it Trump gets the credit
here and my analysis immediately at the
time was yeah more than likely this is
something we can point to South Korea
for having influence on possible
behind-the-scenes influence from China
to the extent that it can be believed at
all that North Korea is actually in good
faith planning to denuclearize and I
also said that with North Korea it's
often in the wording and the semantics
and that something as seemingly
straightforward as we're ready for the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
could mean that North Korea is ready to
stop pursuing nuclear weapons as soon as
for example all American troops from the
nuclear nation of the United States of
America leave South Korea so that was
another factor but in any case what was
clear was that Trump had at best some
coincidental involvement in this
development now North Korea is straight
up saying what we're doing has nothing
to do with anything that Donald Trump
did this is the news from the weekend
let's see what North Korea said and then
we can sort of analyze it for what it's
worth
KCNA is the North Korean news agency
effectively a propaganda channel no
doubt about it they say that the US
should not be deliberately provoking nor
misleading the public by claiming that
Trump had a role because Trump had no
role in this so let's think through it
piece by piece
certainly even if Trump did play a role
in North Korea's seeming willingness to
denuclearize
it wouldn't be shocking if the North
Korean propaganda machine tried to deny
it merely for public relations purposes
but that being said there are trumpets
who immediately credited Trump for North
Korea's willingness to denuclearize who
are now simply saying you can't believe
what North Korea says well if you
believed the North Koreans 10 days ago
when they said they were going to
denuclearize why can't you believe them
now when they also say Trump also had
nothing to do with it but let's zoom out
for a moment and actually think through
on a different level is it that hard to
believe that some tweets from Trump
referring to Kim jong-un as Rocket Man
didn't solve a seventy-year-old problem
with North Korea like is that really so
hard to believe
we also learned after news of the
denuclearization pledge that North Korea
suffered the destruction of their
nuclear weapons testing facility and
that a ton of technical people even died
because of what took place there is it
possible that had more to do with the
need
denuclearization news than Trump's
randomly capitalized tweets and remember
it's really important not to understate
China here I said this last week the
Chinese president along with
consolidating power and eliminating term
limits in China recently did invite Kim
jong-un to China this was the first time
in something like seven years that Kim
jong-un had left North Korea and then a
few weeks after that meeting we hear
about the denuclearization pledge so any
sensible observer here would realize
that politics aside South Korea China
the implosion of North Korea's nuke test
facility those are really the driving
factors here not Donald Trump's tweets
and as a final note I care about being
accurate in placing blame and credit
merely for accuracy's sake but my top
priority as an end goal here is to
better the circumstances for the North
Korean people and I am willing to say
right now giving Donald Trump some
credit will fix the situation I'm not
saying that it will but if it would I
say give Trump credit let Trump take
credit if it allows some greater good
here it just doesn't seem to actually be
supported by any facts and in the end
the most important thing is that they go
through with denuclearization because it
would be a first step and only a first
step but an important one to the people
of North Korea being better off and
that's really my priority here whether
Donald Trump takes credit or gets credit
from Trump asur the South Korean foreign
minister or whoever there's of course
some objective reality about that will
we ever know it 100% with 100% accuracy
maybe not but what we should all be most
focused on is the well-being of the
North Korean people and the reduction in
threat to the people surrounding North
Korea as well which includes South Korea
it includes Americans in Guam and
includes China and Japan and so many
other parts of that region Quickbook
plug by the way if you're interested in
North Korea there is a great fiction
book that I've recommended in the past
and it is called the orphan masters son
by Adam Johnson it's a fiction book it's
a it's a novel but it is based around
Adam Johnson's extensive research and
knowledge of North Korea and it is an
amazing if if not brutal read but I do
highly highly recommend it to you okay
so if you watch or listen to our show
you probably already know that when I
open a story by saying hey there was a
rare moment of sanity on Fox News it's
almost always shepard smith and
sometimes like every once in a while it
will be chris wallace today's the
exception to that trend yes trump was
called out for his lies yes it was on
fox news yes it was a male anchor but it
was not Shep Smith and it was not Chris
Wallace it was actually Neil Cavuto
and the topic was the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in hush money that
repayment admission from Rudy Giuliani
that we've talked about relating to
Trump's repayment of that hush money
Neil Cavuto did a monologue and called
what's going on out as lies but he
didn't actually use that word right but
we could all sort of understand what he
was saying Cavuto made it very clear
that the story is not making any sense
Trump denied any knowledge of it Rudy
Giuliani says Trump did pay back but
then sort of walks it back which we'll
talk about later it's just not making
any sense here is Neil Cavuto on Fox
News pointing this out president Trump
is fond of calling out the media on fake
news but is he the one giving them very
real ammunition maybe not intentionally
I'll even give you the benefit of doubt
mr. president say maybe not deliberately
but consistently way to consistently so
let me be clear mr. president how can
you drain the swamp if you're the one
who keeps muddying the waters you didn't
know about that $130,000 payment to a
porn star I think it did said you knew
nothing about how your former lawyer
Michael Cohen handle this until
acknowledging today you were the guy
behind the retainer payment that took
care of this you insist that money from
the campaign or campaign contributions
played no role in this transaction of
that your short thing is not even 24
hours ago sir you couldn't recall any of
this and you seem very sure now I'm not
saying you're a liar you're president
you're busy I'm just having a devil
time figuring out which news is they
let's just say your own words on lots of
stuff give me shall I'd say lots of
pause like the time you said the
Russians didn't interfere in the 2016
election until a lot of Republicans had
to remind you they did came back months
later and you said well I never said
that Russia didn't meddle in the
election when in fact you had a lot now
none of this makes me a never Trump er
just always confused like when you claim
your tax plan was the biggest in US
history when it wasn't or that the
building is signed to make it all happen
would cost you a fortune when it turns
out it is going to help make you a
bigger fortune or that your job approval
numbers really aren't that bad relative
to other presidents at this stage when
they're actually worse than most
presidents at this stage that can change
but what's weird is this pattern does
not so you get the idea this is probably
the best we can hope for on fox news
other than Shepard Smith and certainly
you know Neil Cavuto doesn't go far
enough here he's still using careful
language it's Fox News after all he's
not going to just say straight up this
guy's been lying to us and clearly
deliberately for a very long time but it
still is a move in the direction of even
Fox News getting to the end of what
they're willing to tolerate from Trump
and then of course predictable the Fox
News audience crushing Cavuto for even
meekly suggesting that maybe some of the
things are revered mr. president has
said might not have been accurate Fox
News viewers have been tweeting just
horrible things to Neil Cavuto calling
him a leftist liberal and a [ __ ] saying
they won't be watching his show anymore
enjoy your low ratings he needs to be
shipped out and the next day Kabuto had
to do sort of a clarification he spent
seven and a half minutes reading angry
tweets and responding to lots of them
individually and sort of saying hey
listen I'm not a never Trump or take a
look anyway fake news works both ways
Kenny so does consistency every fact I
presented last night was real every
comment I used from the president was
his not my words his words word for word
not my tweets his tweet nothing was fake
everything I shared was real no matter
the Bob emails you're a smug pompous
windbag I hope that you croak on that
pork chop tonight
wait a minute yeah the other thing to
bear in mind here is that just because
Neil Cavuto said some of the things our
president has been saying seem to be
inaccurate or inconsistent he and Fox
News don't deserve any journalism awards
right for timidly acquiescing to the
completely undeniable reality that
Trump's not being honest this is one of
the most dishonest presidents in history
the only reason it's notable is that Fox
News has been the propaganda machine for
Trump and if you're white waiting around
for Fox News to take this trend or take
this approach on all of its shows like
Fox and Friends I would not hold my
breath the problem with Fox News being
almost a 100 percent uninterrupted
stream of total propaganda is that you
tell the truth once here just basically
saying sometimes Trump's not 100% honest
and you get crushed and people get
really really mad so the best possible
scenario here is that maybe Fox is
starting to tear itself apart or eat
itself whatever analogy you want to use
the other is this might lead to a total
housecleaning at Fox News to get
everybody 100% on message either away
I'm super interested in watching what
happens on Fox News and you know I don't
watch a lot of MSNBC but a lot of people
think of MSNBC is the left-wing
equivalent of Fox News yeah if an MSNBC
host was critical of Barack Obama or
Hillary Clinton I would actually kind of
like it especially coming from them yeah
if they were being critical on the right
things but you never see that on Fox
News or at least not as much because the
committee Trump is just won't have it
not in the same way yeah and of course
Jen Kyogre from The Young Turks has the
story about how he when he was hosting
on MSNBC and there was a discussion or a
possible longer term job forum how one
of the things he was told was you got to
sort of step away a little bit from the
criticism of President Obama but towards
the end of Obama's presidency you
arguably saw more dissenting voices from
the left on MSNBC in a lot of ways we
are talking about two profit-driven
corporate news outlets whose editorial
positions are different but that dynamic
is one that is going to be very very
hard to break at Fox News especially if
their core profitable audience starts to
turn away because they start to say wait
a second we're not getting
the message that we were expecting and
hoping to get from FoxNews send me your
thoughts what's going on with Cavuto
what do you think is driving him to do
this because he could also just do
another segment right he didn't he
didn't have to do this story I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
in academic circles it's not really
controversial to say that tax cuts for
the rich don't trickle down to workers
you don't you don't really see that as a
controversial thing I've talked about
this hundreds of times on the show I've
explained the logic that tax cuts for
the rich and corporations are not an
incentive big picture to raise salaries
or hire more people because
fundamentally tax cuts for the rich and
businesses make it cheaper to take
profits this came up for example in my
interview with Dave Rubin a few months
ago well Republican Senator Marco Rubio
was recently interviewed by The
Economist and he admitted the money's
not trickling down to workers he said
during his interview there was still a
lot of thinking on the right that if big
corporations are happy they're gonna
take in the money they're saving and
they're going to take the money they're
saving and reinvested in American
workers in fact they bought back shares
a few gave out bonuses there's no
evidence whatsoever that the money's
been massively poured back into the
American worker
there is nothing shocking or
controversial here right but it's
interesting that a Republican senator is
willing to admit this because this is
the Republican policy and philosophy on
taxes period but it's just Marco Rubio
saying one thing maybe he's saying it
because he's prepping for an upcoming
election attempt and he wants to be able
to slam Donald Trump the real question
is why did ruvi Rubio vote for the tax
plan if he didn't think that it would
actually trickle down to workers and is
Rubio not willing to vote for Trump for
re-election on this basis and I would go
even further Democratic congresswoman
Nancy Pelosi has said the same thing
which is that the bonuses are crumbs and
big picture this is not actually good
for workers and even other Democrats in
some cases have slammed Nancy Pelosi but
at least we have a Republican here
willing to admit it but just saying this
to the economist is pretty meaningless
and thus there's more behind it right
and we shouldn't forget that even though
Rubio is saying the bill hasn't done
what we were
that would do Rubio voted for the thing
so either Marco Rubio just learned that
trickle-down supply-side economics don't
work or he knew it when he voted for the
bill and chose to ignore that but
because we haven't talked about tax
policy for a little bit there's an
additional layer to this that I think is
useful which is even if and you're not
going to hear this discussed by
candidates even if supply-side
trickle-down economics somehow did get
companies to reinvest in their
businesses do you know what they're
gonna reinvest in it's not gonna be
raises for employees it's going to be
improving their automation technology
it's going to be making investments that
allow them in the future to spend even
less money and increase profits right
one of the top ways that firms that
corporations compete is on price one of
the best ways to lower prices now that
outsourcing has already been done is get
rid of people altogether and go to
machines right so if there's anything
good that might come from Marco Rubio
being honest about this it's not that we
can count on Rubio to be some kind of
advocate for better tax policy he's not
gonna do that it's that it might trigger
a conversation about the overriding
issues around tax policy in the economy
which is even if critical down works
which it doesn't it's gonna trickle down
and be used to reinvest in automation
technology killing even more jobs like
we're seeing it carrier I remember Rubio
was one of the holdouts in the tax bill
when it was being debated because he
wanted to expand the child tax credit
yes and I think he could have done a lot
more respect especially be was trying to
like stick to a principle there because
it barely passed the Senate if he wanted
to hold out for more something like this
he could have he could if there's just
no indication that he actually doesn't
want to vote for it because of the
trickle-down stuff like he wanted the
child tax credit which is fine right
it's a worthy cause there's no
indication he's actually unwilling to
participate in the voodoo economics of
the Republican right at this point but
hey listen if it triggers a broader
conversation that's useful it's a good
thing but if you're waiting around for
Marco Rubio the progressive tax advocate
it's not going to be Marco Rubio that's
for sure
let's take a quick break back with David
Weintraub after this we've talked about
the many reasons
for which Donald Trump's lawyers would
be right not to want Donald Trump to be
interviewed by special prosecutor Robert
Muller Trump believes himself to be
smarter than everyone in the room so he
might try to live thinking he can get
away with it not knowing what Robert
Muller's team already knows he might
show up and tell truths that expose
criminal behavior on his behalf or the
behalf of people working for him without
him even really knowing which would be
really bad if your Trump's lawyer Trump
might show up and say things that be
they true or false might open up new
lines of Investigation for Robert Muller
so there's a lot of reasons why if your
Trump's lawyer you wouldn't want Trump
speaking to Muller or his investigators
unfortunately for Trump and his lawyers
I told you yesterday that Moeller has
rejected the offer of an interview in
writing where Moeller will send Trump
questions and Trump's lawyers will write
completely sanitized the answers and
that was not good news for Donald Trump
there's more bad news for Trump with
regard to this possible interview which
is that they decided to do a mock Robert
Muller interview and it was a disaster
right they did a sort of practice
session the way one might do before a
presidential debate and the idea was to
get Trump to start practicing the
questions that he might have to answer
if the interview does take place and
they had a whole list of questions they
had for hours during which they were
going to do this and they got through
two questions they got through only two
questions partially because Trump kept
getting interrupted by different things
partially because Trump just wouldn't
shut up and get to the answers
reportedly just going on endlessly about
only tangentially related topics can you
imagine having to train Trump to be
interviewed by skilled criminal
investigators mr. president can you
state your full name for the record I'm
Donald John Trump because actually John
wasn't my dad's middle name people think
it was but it wasn't and I'll tell you
John Trump was my uncle who would
brilliant guy a professor at MIT or
UPenn either way I mean both are great
schools you penned by the way I went to
UPenn graduated first in my class fake
news media won't tell you that Oh Trump
can't read Trump can't capitalize
correctly folks listen the game is over
but
Trump who I was named after we got along
great no obstruction he did really
serious things with nukes and uranium
and nuclear weapons and that's what Iran
wants Iran wants nukes so I had to get
rid of the deal through the Iran deal
right in the trash it's done is that a
yes on your name is Donald John Trump
sir I do not envy Trump's lawyers for a
second in having to do this well we know
that Robert Muller's investigation is
pretty wide-ranging and the applicants
have been complaining about that of
course look Muller asks about Donald
Trump's big beautiful businesses or his
massive 2016 election victory Trump will
be okay then he'll he would love to
answer those questions no question about
it there actually is a silver lining
here like if I have to find some good
news here the FET for us not for Trump
the fact that they're doing mock
interview suggests that on some level
they are thinking he might have to sit
down with Muller right whether it's with
or without a subpoena but given how the
mock interview went his lawyers would be
nutty to let Trump walk in there
voluntarily and if the Trump Moeller
interview was televised on pay-per-view
it would raise enough money to end
poverty right I mean this this is this
would be the most compelling television
I can imagine and this is why I'm
actually worried about the pulling out
of the Iran deal being a smokescreen to
start providing some pre-emptive cover
and we know that Trump will go very very
far in doing whatever he perceives he
has to do with Iran or Syria or both
just to keep attention off of the
growing heat from Robert Muller and I
don't know what the timeline is on this
possible interview we heard from Rudy
Giuliani Trump's newest lawyer that he
hopes he needs time to get up to speed
and doesn't want to even talk about an
interview I think he said until after
the North Korea summit right so it could
be a while Giuliani is so trustworthy I
mean I'm sure we can take his word yeah
it's like do we even have any reason to
believe Giuliani has talked to anybody
about what the timeline is for the
interview maybe not but not good news
for Trump and I am I'm starting to look
forward to you know we had the Michael
Flint indictment that was a
much-anticipated event in this entire
saga we had
James commis first interview timed of
course with the release of his book
which people were very much anticipating
I was sort of anticipating those things
Trump sitting down with Moeller and we
don't even know when we would learn
about what takes place during that
interview that to me is really sort of
at the top of the pyramid of what I'm
waiting for yeah although unfortunately
it won't be televised I think the next
bombshell yeah might be Jared Kushner
indictment or Donald Trump jr.
indictment that I have to see I think
Michael Cohen indictment happens before
that right yeah let me think I mean it
Kushner and Trump jr. it seems to me
that Moeller has been waiting on the
family until later on and maybe that's
why Ivanka Trump hasn't been pulled in
yet either but we don't know we don't
know what's going on with Muller
needless to say four hours to answer two
questions not great although maybe it's
a strategy maybe if Trump takes four
hours to answer two questions when he
sits down with Muller
Muller just won't be able to really ask
that many questions and maybe that's
what Trump wants discuss this with us on
our subreddit david pakman.com slash re
d di t Chris Martenson joins me next so
let's follow up a little bit on the
Michael Cohen story yesterday I reported
to you about this just massive massive
story of how Michael Cohen Trump's
personal attorney received over a
million dollars in payments through a
shell company that we specifically know
of allegedly more than four million
dollars in total the details of which we
don't yet fully know 200k from AT&T that
we now learned was probably closer to
six hundred thousand four hundred
thousand from Novartis which Novartis
has now admitted was actually 1.2
million dollars
supposedly five hundred thousand from a
Russian oligarch tied to Vladimir Putin
this is a story about criminality it's a
story about swamp filling it's a story
related to the molar investigation and
to Trump and Cohen and cronyism and
corruption it's one of the biggest
stories in a while and Fox News during
the three-hour period falling following
these revelations simply didn't cover it
Tucker Carlson for example during
primetime had plenty of time to talk
about an outrageous mural showing Donald
Trump on a spear plenty of time for that
Michael a vanadis tweet about this was
mentioned on Bret Bayers show right
before 7:00 p.m. Eastern
it was dismissed by a Republican
lobbyist as nonsense I'll play that clip
for you a little bit later and then
Michael Cohen's name was not mentioned
again until after 11:00 p.m. Eastern
Time
then the following morning same thing
mentioned in passing on Fox and Friends
no real coverage 5 total minutes were
spent on the Michael Cohen revelations
in the something like 15 hours following
the revelations of the story and this is
part of Fox News protecting Trump and it
leads to something I've called
informational incongruity before we've
talked about this now a couple times on
the show if we all agree on what the
important issues are we can debate the
issue if we all at least know what
issues are we can debate their
importance if we don't even know what's
going on at the most fundamental levels
of government and grow government
cronies we have no real ability to
actually debate and the Fox News
audience would have no idea what's going
on with Michael Cohen and thus it
wouldn't even figure into their
calculation about how serious these
allegations are which is really great
for Donald Trump and the sort of as a
really funny sidebar the moment this
came up on Bret Bayers show right so at
7:00 p.m. the primetime blackout started
on Fox News just before 7:00 p.m. on
Bret Baier 6:00 p.m. show this is
briefly mentioned and Republican
lobbyist match slap happened to be on
Bret Bayers show at the time and he said
don't worry about this Michael Cohen
stuff it doesn't prove that there's any
Russian collusion a total red herring
right here's the clip from Fox News do
another thing just happened before we
went on air Matt Michael avenatti the
attorney for stormy Daniels tweets out
after significant investigation we've
discovered that mr. Trump's attorney mr.
Cohen received approximately $500,000 in
the months after the election from a
company controlled by a Russian oligarch
with close ties to mr. Putin these
monies may have reimbursed the 130,000
payment to stormy Daniels we've reached
out to Michael Cohen and his attorney no
response yet multiple different agencies
reporting about this this payment
what about this this is think why the
American people get frustrated I don't
know if mr. avenatti is stormy Daniels
lawyer or if he's the lawyer for hashtag
resistance to try to do everything he
can to weaken the president I think this
is like several bank shots I guess to
show that there's some kind of collusion
with Russia and I think the American
people are fair and if there is no
proven collusion with Russia that
impacted the election I think they are
tired of all the theatrics with this
investigation show us what you have give
us the facts and let's move on as a
country and obviously nothing coming
from the Muller team as of yet we'll
continue to follow up on that fine of
$1,000.00 just the best right so first
this guy says listen whether michael
cohen received millions of dollars from
people trying to buy influence with
donald trump it doesn't prove prove that
there was russian collusion but who's
saying that those two things are
directly linked other than the fact that
there was a Russian oligarch allegedly
involved but this is not actually about
Russian collusion we're talking about
possible bribes here it is a completely
different story although still you don't
ever get that far from Russia there
seemed to always be Russians involved
but also notice the words that slap used
he said unless we see proof of Russian
collusion that influenced the results of
the election that is another goalposts
move because before it was there was no
Russian collusion then it became if
there was collusion then it wouldn't
have been illegal and now unless we
prove that the election results were
actually flipped by that Russian
collusion then nobody should care about
this is something that you will see
happen very very often it is goal posts
moving and it is also a distraction and
the bigger story now then that they're
going to forever move the goalposts is
that this is something above and beyond
what we even conceived of when this
entire thing started you weren't gonna
hear about it on Fox News though they
were definitely not going to tell you
about what was going on I understand
those people who say that we should
focus more on things like health care
and jobs and maybe less on Russia or
stormy Daniels and all that stuff point
taken but when you have a 24/7 news show
and this is the top story at the time
you can't explain away a four-hour black
on a major channel well you can explain
it away as this is a concerted effort to
protect the president right I mean the
the on what the explanations are really
bad and there's no benign way to explain
it away for sure tonight on Hannity why
is that the fact that Michael Cohen was
being paid by AT&T actually about killer
he's uranium one deal very very big
breaking story tonight on Hannity send
me your thoughts about the blackout send
me your thoughts about what's going on
with Michael Cohen I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
remember when Donald Trump and
Republicans passed their tax plan and I
told you that this tax plan was going to
allow Donald Trump to claim two
victories victory number one that he did
tax reform even though the tax reform he
did was the opposite of what the tax
reform he promised to do would have done
in terms of its effect on on people
secondly the tax bill would allow Trump
to say that he repealed Obamacare it's
not true but it was going to let him say
it the tax plan that Trump and
Republicans passed did make a change to
Obamacare it eliminated the individual
health care mandate which says every
individual must have some kind of
insurance or pay a fine but Trump is now
selling it as if he did straight-up get
rid of Obamacare Trump did another one
of these really weird rallies in
Michigan recently and he said
essentially we are getting rid of
Obamacare some people would say
essentially we have gotten rid of it now
this is a lie but this is predictable we
knew that Donald Trump was going to sell
this to his followers as having put
Obamacare in total in the trash even
though most of Obamacare is still in
place but there's another further layer
to tump Trump's lie the Trump
administration is actually enforcing
some aspects of Obamacare more strongly
then the Obama administration did and
Republicans as well as some business
owners are angry with Trump for that so
for example Trump got rid of the
individual mandate but the employer
mandate is still there the employer
mandate says if you have a company with
more than 50 full-time employees you
must offer health insurance to workers
or pay a fine that's still in place and
according to numerous reports that is
not just in writing as part of the law
it is being enforced businesses are
actually being fined under Trump for not
offering health care when they're
supposed to based on Obamacare law so
the big picture is the exchanges still
exist the coverage requirements exist
right health insurers aren't allowed to
go back to those disastrous plans that
didn't even meet the minimum insurance
insurance conditions of Obamacare the
pre-existing conditions requirement is
still there the corporate mandate is
still there it's all still there other
than the individual mandate Obamacare in
total exists with the exception that if
you don't have coverage you won't pay a
fine and all that does is make coverage
more expensive for people because the
idea is the fines make more people
choose to have coverage that grows the
risk pool spreads risk among more people
and in principle companies don't have to
charge as much for health insurance so
this is not a matter of opinion right it
is a lie to say that Donald Trump has
gotten rid of Obamacare whether he says
we essentially got rid of it or we got
rid of it either way it's not true and
there's a funny and tragic element to
this which is that Trump said dozens or
hundreds of times during the campaign
that he would not only get rid of
Obamacare but he was gonna replace it
with a beautiful new system where
everyone would be covered for less money
than under Obamacare if Trump believes
that he got rid of Obamacare which is
what he's saying he did where is the
beautiful replacement that he told us we
would have because even if he claims to
have gotten rid of Obamacare which he
didn't there's no question that he
hasn't come up with a replacement which
he also said that he would do normal
people would realize that this is a lie
right and the most interesting
perspective I'm thinking about is are
enough Republicans falling for this that
it will actually earn him votes in the
fall like in other words are people
going to reward Trump and Republicans
for quote getting rid of Obamacare even
though they didn't and vote for
Republicans and Trump in November
because in reality if they want to vote
on the basis of did Trump do what he
said he would do they should not be
voting for Trump
I have a feeling that this is going to
convince a lot of people I think this is
the lie that he will get away with and
it's because most Trump supporters
aren't employers with 50 or more
employees so they don't have to deal
with that correct the thing that they
didn't like about Obamacare was the
individual mandate and maybe they liked
some of the other specific provisions
like staying on your parents health care
till you were 26 sure so in the eyes of
most people he did what he set out to do
mission accomplished there's another
issue also which is that not only are
most Trump voters as you're saying not
owners of businesses with more than 50
full-time employees they're also mostly
not on marketplace plans meaning most of
them have insurance through their
employer so they're not even connected
to this individual mandate like it
existed for a while and it didn't impact
them and then now it's gone and it still
doesn't impact them and it's completely
a sort of academic or theoretical thing
so I think you're completely right this
is a lie that Trump is going to benefit
from he did it he got rid of Obamacare
even though he got rid of one percent of
Obamacare or five percent one specific
provision here that's my question to you
will Republican voters fall for this lie
from Donald Trump I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show